thank you very much yes it certain
elements of faith are by definition
exclusivist whether we would like them
to be soaked or not for example large
segments of Christianity believe very
strongly that unless you accept Jesus
Christ as your personal Lord and Savior
you're basically excluded from God's
grace that very belief is is of course
anatomical to non-muslims are to book to
Muslims they would believe that that
that very belief makes you outside of
God's grace or and not believing in the
prophets of God as well so the question
arises we're not going to be able to
change these fundamental theological
beliefs what practical steps can we do I
mean how can we make people genuinely
love and care about one another when
they believe that that other person who
is outside their faith tradition is
outside of God's grace that's a great
question wish I knew the answer that's a
great question I I think one of the
things that we should explore in the
course of this is the nature of that
kind of exclusionary belief because
that's not limited Christianity I either
is it so I mean each faith will believe
that it has the truth and and the
question really will be is there a way
that people can feel comfortable whilst
they believe that they have the truth
with the truth of somebody else you know
are the ways that we can can make that
an experience that people don't find
threatening or off-putting just to give
you an example when I it's just
reflecting because of course with the
Quran being the given word of god to to
the Prophet
that obviously has a very special
significance within Islam in what you
read The Book of Leviticus the Lord
gives the laws to Moses and speaks
directly to him now when we end our
Christian Bible readings we will say
this is the word of the Lord or this is
the word of God and I think one thing
that we can explore and this is why if
we can get the right partnerships with
people I also want to do some of some of
the forgive me for all politicians think
some of the polling on them attitudes
and so on is to work out what people
really mean by that sense of I have the
truth the degree to which they hold that
in an exclusionary way and whether there
are areas in which you can start to see
some somewhere that people can come
together a bit around that you know now
I think because I think that is a so
really and it will raise the issue of
the degree to which faith when it is
exclusionary arises out of doctrine or
is it a rising out of attitude and I
think that so that is what we need to
explore but my own view is that that
people actually can find a way through
that if they want to